>> My name is Aaron McCormack.
I'm the Chief Executive Officer of BT Conferencing
with the India
Economic Summit in New Delhi.
I think it's fair to say that India is going
to be a global superpower.
I think that our definition of what constitutes
a superpower is out of
date.
I believe that soft power and economic power
and influence are becoming
much more important than hard military definitions
of what a superpower
is.
I believe that India's levels of innovations
and the sheer size of the
country, and the fact that scarcity is driving
levels of innovation
that are not seen in other parts of the world
pretty much predestines
India to become one of the major superpowers
of the 21st century.
I think it is ready.